what's up guys and welcome to Horizonte
SD Chinna where we discussed the latest
tech news and delve into the newest tech
products today we're taking a look at
how low GPU prices will go and whether
you should buy one right now or wait a
little bit longer but before we get into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to stay
updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so starting
off if you guys haven't noticed GPU
prices have been consistently going down
for the past couple of months now and
many of them were actually really close
to MSRP for example the gtx 1066
gigabyte card came out for an MSRP of
$250 and today you can get that card for
just $300 so only $50 more and this
trading action continues out the other
GPUs as well for example if you look at
gtx 1070 that came out for an MSRP of
379 dollars now you can get it for for
$169 so about $90 more aspersa GTX 1080
the GTX today is actually being offered
for less than Ana's RP the MSRP for the
GTX to Navy founders Edition was six
hundred ninety nine dollars and for
third-party ones it was five hundred
ninety nine dollars but today you can
actually get at asus strix
rog gtx 280 on super busy with the
mail-in rebate or five hundred eighty
dollars so it's actually less than MSRP
and if you guys are interested in that
deal and make sure to click on the link
in the description down below
unfortunately however the GTX 1080i is
still quite inflated the MSRP for GTX
1080i is seven hundred dollars and most
gtx ten ATT eyes are still at least nine
hundred and fifty dollars so it's still
two hundred fifty dollars or more above
MSRP but with the vast majority of cards
it's only about 50 to 100 dollars over
MSRP and it's still going down
so all these cards should hit MSRP very
soon so what exactly happened and why is
there this huge price tip recently well
recently actually it 3m dropped from
over $1400 to
than $400 in just a couple of months and
if you guys didn't know cerium is one of
the most popular cooker currencies to be
mined with GPUs and obviously it's price
drop has been deterring many people from
entering the GPU scene and many people
who are already in it to not expand
further and as a result that has led to
less GPU demand from miners on top of
this the difficulty to my
cryptocurrencies across the board not to
secure them is getting much more
difficult and as a result that too is to
turning miners on top of this there's
actually a new ASIC specifically
designed for a theorem as coming out
very soon from a company named bit me
and this new basic is promising really
good power for example it's supposed to
be 20 times more powerful than a GTX 10
atti which is fully overclocked but it's
only supposed to take double the amount
of power so as you guys can see it's
very very efficient on top of this the
price of that new ASIC should also be
very favorable to miners but it's a
specific design for mining and so it's
price to performance should be much
better than what GPUs can ever offer I
know that Asics reduce the diversity
that miners have but if the performance
is that good and many GPU miners only
want to mine it theorem anyways so this
will definitely attract a lot of miners
away from GPUs overall they're just not
that crazy hyper on cryptocurrency that
they used to be and as a result there's
much less people entering the scene and
while you can still make money from
mining it's just not that simple fast
way to make a quick buck and as a result
there's much less demand for GPUs from
miners and as a result GPU prices are
going down on top of this ramp prices
are looking much better as well for
example let's take a look at ddr4 in the
Corsair Vengeance RGB 2666 Ram watched
over $200 at $210 just a couple months
ago and while there is quite a way still
to reach MSRP it is slowly dropping and
it will reach MSRP very soon
furthermore many gamers are being taken
off the equation as well please a lot of
them who really want a GPU have resorted
to buying used GPUs or just paying the
extra price and as a result they're just
overall much less demand on the GPU
market and the RAM price is not inflated
and on top of this NVIDIA has been
telling us that they have been trying to
raise its stock for a couple of months
now so as a result the combination of
all three of these things have been
consistently leading to price drops and
I think that it will reach MSRP very
soon honestly in my opinion I think that
most graphics horse at least remain
video will reach MSRP by the end of May
if anything it will be a max of $50 over
MSRP now you guys may be like but what
about RAM well I know that Ram is
definitely leading to some price
inflation but I don't think it's a very
big cause because for example in
November RAM prices were much worse than
what they are right now but even despite
that you can you pick up a gtx 1080 with
the game for only $500 and other GPUs
were also priced better so as a result
these companies can offer these GPUs for
less than MSRP even though Ram prices
are quite inflated now this is just what
I believe so if you guys think something
else will happen then make sure to
comment that down below so this is all
great and all but should you buy a new
graphics card soon well you're
definitely not going to be ripped off
anymore but it still may be a good
option to consider waiting because the
next series from Nvidia called Nvidia
Turing is coming out very soon and is
expected in July or August of this year
now they're all has also been there has
also been a huge leak that is suggesting
really good performance for the gtx 1180
this rumor is suggesting that the gtx
1180 will actually perform on a level up
to titan XP now before we continue just
make sure to keep in mind that these are
just leaks and it could very well be
false and also if you guys are
interested
full details of this leak then make sure
to check out my full video on that but
here's just a quick recap the new gtx
according to this leak is supposed to
have 3584 cuda cores now if you look at
the titan XP that only has three
thousand eight hundred and forty so it's
very close and on top of this it's
supposed to be more power efficient as
well at about one hundred two hundred
watts instead of 250 watts for the titan
XP also on top of that the GTS calamity
will support GD r six memory instead of
the gddr5 X memory found on the Titan XP
so as a result the performance of the
GTX lemon II looks very promising and
according to these leaks should match if
not exceed the performance of the Titan
X P so now that's great and all and it
could very well happen because NVIDIA
has a lot of performance and it's not
like they're giving us too much of what
they have but how much will it cost
well according to sleek it's only
supposed to cost $700 for the GTX 1180
so if you guys remember the GTX 1080
came out for that same MSRP of $700 for
the founders edition cards so we may
actually be able to find GTX Lebanese
from Asus or MSI or gigabyte our EVGA
for $500 just like what happened with
the GTX 280 so as you guys can see it's
a lot better performance for the same
price that the GTX 280 is supposed to
cost so it may definitely be worth
considering to wait so that's great and
all but that's really only for the
higher level cards like the 1170 at 1180
which are going to be coming out in July
or August but what about lower level
cars like the 1150 and 1160 well
unfortunately those aren't expected to
come out till the end of the year but if
you really don't need an upgrade now
then it still may be worth considering
to wait for those as well and on top of
that if you think about it one stat 1170
and 1180 comes out the GTX 1050 1060
1070 and today t will all drop in Christ
so you may even be able to afford 1070
or 1080 once the GTX 1170 and lemony
come out so that's a plus as well
overall the
generation of GPUs are very close and I
definitely think that you guys should
consider waiting for them because they
offer much better performance for a much
cheaper price despite what GPU level
you're looking for so here's the gist of
what happened GPU prices are probably
going to hit MSRP very soon because
there is much less demand for miners and
gamers and RAM price are doing much
better however it may still be worth
considering to wait a little bit longer
for the next series of GPUs or Nvidia
things they will come out for about the
same price but
but provide much superior performance it
may also be worth waiting to get a 10
series card because those will probably
drop once the new 11 series cards come
out at the same time there is now no
shame in buying a 10 Series card because
they are actually reasonably priced and
it does make sense if you guys just
flat-out done waiting for anything else
so what do you guys think do you guys
think that it's definitely worth waiting
for the new gtx 1180 and 1170 or do you
not care about the performance that
these new cards can offer you just want
to buy a reasonably priced GPU as soon
as possible make sure to post down the
comments below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
to drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this but until
next time bye
[Music]